growth rates now uh i should probably
put inverted commas
around growth rates okay because the
whole idea behind this is that when you
say
um growth rate how fast something is
getting bigger or smaller there are
actually
five different things that could be met
by this idea of the growth rate okay
and what you hear about the growth rate
like what kind of additional
descriptions
there are will tell you which of the
five it is okay so i'm going to try and
um go through them one at a time
now we've got some different categories
okay so up on the top these two rows
here
they have to do with time
okay they're to do with time uh whereas
these vertical ones are to do with um
how do i say this it's not like units i
suppose
you'll see why in a second now remember
we were talking right at the beginning
about why differentiation and calculus
comes into this topic
okay namely that if you want to know how
fast something is growing okay and you
know how much you've got of it
the thing you do is you differentiate
now the cool thing about having a
function right
and knowing its derivative okay
even though we call that the gradient
function it's something
quite different to knowing gradient
right
because the gradient function gives you
a precise
gradient at a particular point as
opposed to to get a gradient you need
two points don't you and then you do
rise and runners okay
so therefore the two distinctions
between time correspond to these two
ideas
okay so the first most important time
is an instantaneous
growth rate okay in other words you know
in other words you freeze your situation
your scenario
at a particular point t equals something
and then you say okay
at this moment in time not even a second
or
a minute okay at this instant how fast
is growing
right now the the opposite to
instantaneous is to
think about it over a period of time
right
so instead of here's am sorry i'll do
just one part
here's something that's growing
exponentially right
to get that instantaneous uh growth rate
you're sort of getting that gradient
right so it's at a point
but you can also think about it as two
different times so you've got the same
growing thing
right you can say well we started off
here
and then a few time units later we get
up to there
so you work out okay what's that
difference right
how long did it take us to get there run
and then you work out a gradient okay
now what would you call this
versus this right um this is sort of
like velocity
right at a particular point this is kind
of like
average speed right it's over a time
it has changed throughout the time but
you get a general idea of what's
happening
so instead of instantaneous
you'll often see average growth rates
tell me the average growth rate for the
first five years
all right now in those first five years
maybe every year had a different growth
rate but you take the average of all of
them
and you'll get one growth rate okay
now we're gonna get into the details of
how that plays out here but
there's also other ways to think about
right
well how much is it growing um in
relation to what
so for instance the most common way to
think about it is
in terms of absolute units okay so if
you've got
a mass that's decaying the absolute unit
would be
grams right or kilograms how much actual
stuff are you losing
or you're talking about a population
right you're like how many people how
many rabbits how many bacteria
right so that's the units are in
absolute terms there
but sometimes they want you to say okay
how's it growing in proportion to
where you started okay i was here and
now i've got
not 100 rabbits more but i've got 10
more rabbits or 20
more rabbits okay so because it's a it's
a percent
it's a proportion it's kind of uh
unitless okay
now the last thing you might actually
want apart from say a number of rabbits
or bacteria
or a percentage is you might actually
just want the function okay
which is different again right it's it's
even
less kind of units than this this is
like a percentage or ratio right
derivatives have no units whatsoever
okay
so what do each of these mean when we
put them together
right well instantaneous
absolute instantaneous absolute so i'm
at a particular point in time
so it's going to have to do with the
derivative okay and then i want well
okay how many rabbits are we gaining
this year at this particular point in
time
how many bacteria right so if we call it
let's say our function is
p okay p for population
should
okay um what was that okay if we call p
our function right instantaneously
absolute i'm going to what the
derivative which is
dpdt
right but i want it at a particular
point in time
right so i want dv to t when
t is equal to i don't know some value
which you specify
you know at the end of the tenth year or
at the end of the fifth second or
something like that
okay so i'm using t1
to distinguish between t t1 is an actual
value
okay so you can say t1 is
real okay now maybe a more concise way
to write this even though i don't like
it
um it is more concise so i'm going to
put it in for you which is dp only t as
the first derivative right so you call
that you could call that p dash
right so this is all equal to p
dash at a particular place namely
t1
so uh that's a one right and um that's a
dash
so this is why i don't like dashes but
it's still a nice concise way to say
okay okay now uh let's keep going now
if we want the average growth rate
as an absolute like how many of my
actual things okay
how do you work that out we'll come back
to our situation here okay what you're
going to do is you're going to say
how many things did i gain over this
time period
how many did i gain so how do you work
out how many you've gained
you've got to know how many you had at
the beginning and then you've got to
know
how many you had at the end right so
how many you had is p the population
you're going to want to know
the population at your end time call
that
time 2
and then you subtract what you started
with right
ok now that's going to tell you the
change in population right
but it's not going to tell you a rate
okay
so what am i going to do how am i going
to turn a number
right between time two and time one i
gained five thousand rabbits
how am i to turn that into a rate
good i want to divide by well how long
did it take me
to rise from this population to that one
right
if i'm comparing you know year 5 and
year 10 i'm going to go
10 minus 5. so the duration was 5 years
there's my change there's how long it
took let's just rise everywhere
okay